is a movie based on a theme park rider
you could be good just been a good idea
in the past it's been a crappy idea in
the past the trailers were super vague
so no one really knows much about the
movie going into it so we might as well
be in no-man's land at this point
better yet we might as well be in
tomorrow land so tomorrow land is a
movie where I'm gonna be super vague
because the trailers were super vague
and had a respect for the trailers I'm
going to I'm not gonna spoil the movie
or really tell you detailed plot points
about the movie because in a day and age
where trailers spoil everything I I like
the fact that this trailer didn't really
show much of anything it was like
Tomorrowland what is it why is it coming
this man turnout here that's awesome so
for the Cygnus reviewed the premise is
there's this girl she finds a button
every time she touches the button she
sees this Tomorrowland like she's there
so with the help of this other little
girl they have to find George Clooney
and together they need to somehow get to
Tomorrowland and it's a pretty fun road
getting to Tomorrowland first of all
everyone in the movie does a really good
job George Clooney does a good job I
really don't have to intro George
Clooney it's like at a point yours like
you know what we all forgot about Batman
and Robin because you're actually really
good at what you do he doesn't let it
slip in this movie he is not phoning it
in he's giving it as all be so easy for
George Clooney to be like oh you mean
I'm gonna be in a futuristic ish movie
that might be the next Pirates of the
Caribbean alright sign me up I'll say a
few lines that we'll be out of here
watching this movie you're like you care
about this okay great can't say that
about everybody working in Hollywood
these days so good job George Clooney
the main girl in this movie Britt
Robertson I don't know much about her
but odds are you're gonna know more
about her after this movie she was
really good in the movie - this girl has
to hold most of the movie up on her
shoulders she can't just be behind
George Clooney while he's spouting off
lines because ultimately George
Clooney's not the main character she is
they don't actually get to George
Clooney until later so it's really on
this girl to make this movie work and
she does a really good job they're
rooting for her you're along for the
ride with her and there's this other
little girl that's helping her out
I don't know her name and I really
should it's really hard to have a little
kid in your movie for as much screen
time as this girl gets and have it work
but she totally makes it work and I like
the fact this movie had a really cool
way of unraveling the plot it doesn't
tell you everything out the gate you're
just getting little scraps it's like
breadcrumbs that you're following with
the characters in the movie you're
learning it along with the main girl in
this movie so you don't actually figure
out what's going on until far into the
movie sometimes you need to know the
plot right out the gate sometimes you
need to know that the droids have the
Death Star plans early on in the movie
and if they get it to the rebellion they
can actually wipe out the Death Star but
you know in certain movies but it's much
harder to execute the plot the way they
do in Tomorrowland fact they pulled it
off props it just felt like an adventure
more than a few occasions I felt like I
kid again going on this adventure with
these kids I can't say that about a lot
of movies nowadays that was just a
really good feeling to have in my adult
life however this movie does suffer from
human nature I guess she's a really
weird thing to say about a movie but
here's what I mean the trailers to this
movie were really vague so people were
kind of left to their own devices to
make up like wool maybe what's
Tomorrowland about well maybe I'm just
gonna piece it together in my head all
right maybe I think it's about this
maybe I think it's about that what is
Tomorrowland lets see Tomorrowland the
fact is it's not really about
Tomorrowland it's about getting to
Tomorrowland so people will be like
where's Tomorrowland oh it's at the last
act of the movie okay and that might
piss some people off when I first walked
out of the movie I kind of thought about
it like maybe all right imagine there
was a movie called Neverland and it's
about Peter Pan and neverland however
most of the movie is about getting to
Neverland figuring out that second start
of the race straight on till morning is
how you get there so it's more about the
journey rather than the destination fact
is it's an interesting journey just
don't want people to not expect that
going into this movie I guess and the
last act of this movie is pretty much
that oh yeah I've seen this a hundred
times before feeling which wouldn't
matter but it's the contrast between
that and the rest of the movie the rest
of the movie is just really cool
adventure I love the characters I love
the journey I love the path I love the
little revelations I love the bread
crumbs that we're following it's really
cool and then you get to the end and
ultimately it's like ah villains Simon
bar sinister is doing something yeah
because villains are villains and
villain villain and this message that
they beat over your head that's just
kind of a vague message about humanity
that you have heard a hundred times over
over the past couple if not few decades
which is such conflicting tone in the
movie I stepped back and I was like
that's that's a bummer
you can't help but have it smack you in
the face the guys in the end
Tomorrowland I loved the characters I
loved the emotion there are actually a
few parts of emotion I was like oh wow
didn't expect that for the most part I
really enjoyed this movie I will say in
the end Tomorrowland is definitely a
good time no alcohol required so
Tomorrowland have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more